yo what's up it's your boy can sign my
boxing gyms they don't know I'm here so
I'm excited to see their reaction let's
do this
one two backhand
backhands all right I'm about to head in
real quick
[Music]
all right
guys
[Music]
let's stop just jab jab okay all right
so you want to try and keep a knee chin
right there and when you punch you want
to like twist it yeah yeah so it's kind
of like like that boom just in yeah keep
it strong keep it strong
so make sure you cleanse your fist as
well when you do it yeah yeah
lots of muscles
I think about the body as well man don't
neglect the body
double Jabs as well
nice nice good sparring boys good spot
good spawn good spot man
hella daunting but all right hi everyone
uh q a you guys ready
hit me up with your questions what's up
all right go for it who do you think
wins Tommy Fury you are Jake Paul
honestly I think Jake Paul as much as I
hate to say it is gonna win yeah I just
I truly think Jake Paul has a better
mindset and want it more than Tommy and
I I don't think Jake is a bad boxer than
Tommy Fury but I think Tommy Fury just
is just
just up here all over the place at the
moment
uh end of the year yeah yeah hopefully
December uh yeah
what has been my lowest moment oh gosh
we're getting deep
um oh man I've had so many low moments I
think one hard moment to deal with
boxing uh since we're in a boxing ring
was when I was in Camp uh against Logan
Paul oh yeah against Logan Paul the
second time when I was in Vegas there
was a period where I was just like this
boxing thing ain't cut out for me man I
was like this this is too hard the
sparring is is just too hard and I'm
just not getting it and yeah it did you
know it broke me down like to the point
where I was you know I was crying man
like I just I hated I was like this is
just one of the hardest things I've ever
done in my life and I don't know how I'm
gonna get through it I felt like I'm
just gonna get get go in that fight and
lose and then you know I kind of just
you know gathered my thoughts really you
know
figured out what I wanted to do and you
know really just
you know I guess stay focused on the
goal and I wasn't too focused on the
destination on like just winning I was
just there like you know what let me
just enjoy this journey you know this
and push myself to the Limit and just
see see what happens and you know with
that I used you know the word that I use
a lot Legacy I just I'd said that a lot
in my head and I was like you know I
want to create an amazing Legacy that
you know one day when you know when I
hang up the gloves or when I finish this
all people will look at me and be like
you know what he was a guy that started
in this bedroom just you know with a
dream just making random videos and now
look at him he's able to you know fight
people in sold out Arenas or he's able
to sing rap you know in arenas sold out
or he's able to you know make YouTube
videos with his mates you know all over
the world so it's kind of just yeah just
trying to figure out what you want
what's up what's up
uh was the camera add inches because
you're not a mini six foot
wow how tall are you
five for nine all right stand up come on
yeah
five foot oh damn you're a big five foot
nine bro
five foot nine months you're sure hey
who's taller who's taller
yeah yeah yeah include the hair as well
man the little button all right all
right well you're looking more is like
six foot to me man
which would make me six ones so we're
blessed uh yeah what's up man who's your
top five for influencers I I put Jake
Paul number one
uh I'd say I'm I'm second uh
third
me I mean I love chunks
uh I'd say a lot of people are saying
salt puppy so Papi's in there probably a
third fourth maybe someone like Dean the
Great
16 the great and maybe
I maybe Gable slim fifth maybe I'll
probably put
I'll probably put slim let's put slim
yeah what about the family what sideways
none of them want to fight man the side
went to no one on five bro Harry scared
Harry's scared of getting hit in the
face uh yeah
I mean I was hella introvert yeah yeah I
just stay indoors a lot I never
um did sleepovers I I hardly went to any
parties I was just really like to myself
and I lived on the internet a lot but um
yeah I didn't have too many friends I
kept quite close a lot of my friends
were online and uh yeah it was it was
very different to other teenagers yeah
who just you know are able to like have
a lot of fun but you know I just started
drinking what alcohol at 19. that's how
like late I was to everything uh yeah
revolver uh Arsenal win the league or
beat Jake Paul
uh oh BJ Paul man yeah yeah because then
Arsenal will win the next year yeah bro
also on smoke this season man will win
it easy
what are you doing man come on there's
kids here
uh yeah what's up
who's the most famous person in your
phone book I mean it's probably speed
right now man like I think most
people I think most people know I think
I think more people will probably know
speed than soccer like in America
especially like a lot of people don't
really know too much about soccer in
America I don't know maybe I could be
wrong but I think probably speed yeah
he's always calling me as well man yeah
he's wrong what made you do boxing what
made me do bro it was an accident
I didn't want to do it I literally I
said I'll fight the winner between Joe
Weller and Theo Baker and they fought
Joe Weller won and I was like I was a
joke no I don't want to actually fight
but my mom was like no no bro I want
that smoke you called for it so let's go
so yeah I kind of fell into it yeah I
know now look yeah it's mine
but uh yeah go for it what should go
after being J pool I think at that point
I kind of just want to build Misfits and
make it as big as like the WWE or the
UFC you know I want to you know still do
sideman videos I still want to you know
post YouTube videos on my own channel uh
just whenever I can you know I want to
really focus on music as well try and
make as much good music as possible and
uh yeah I guess if it makes sense to
come back into the ring if something
excites me or entices me then yeah I'll
get back and knock out another man
let me let me say it appreciate it for
each and every one of them I appreciate
it guys
[Music]
all right
say cheese
[Music]
I appreciate it guys thank you so much
guys
all right I'm off see you guys in a bit
take care
yeah that was fun it was good to see the
kids and uh yeah I hope to do more of
that in the future that was the best
experience best experience of my life
I've met turkey and now I've met cancer
my heart is pounding I'm about to fade
it was fun it was good I like the energy
of cancer I like everything about it I
didn't really expect him to come before
be some random guy
I thought it was going to be some random
person that no one knows but it turned
out to be KSI one of my biggest Heroes
yeah Heroes to grown up first day of
your life yes 100 yes 100 yes 10 000 to
Infinity I've been wanting to meet ksr
for long I've been a fan for him for
quite a while when I was young really
watch this videos growing up I even
messaged him asking him to come here
when I don't know when I've got the
message here
um
13th 13th of October last year and sent
him a message told him to maybe like
come down to a boxing session and yeah
it happens
yeah it's a bit of a dream come true
I'll be real for us it's you know giving
the kids a chance to see somebody they
look up to in their home it gives them
that motivation to kind of come back to
these places oh I've seen somebody that
I love come to this gym and when I was
here he advised me to keep working hard
and you can tell they enjoy themselves
they really did enjoy that opportunity
because our sessions are normally just
regular boxing run around the gym do
this get tired and then go home but now
we've got somebody they will love turn
up it's like oh my God now it's exciting
they're all gonna go to school tomorrow
like it's gonna but it's great like
that's what it's about it's about
building that connection with all of
these young people and getting them to
feel that positivity when they come
somewhere like this so they keep coming
[Music]
oh bro what that smells like [__] ass
my in Ash juice what is this
Nigeria what are you doing